hello all and I am on location in
California which is a fancy way of
saying I still don't have any of my cool
[ __ ] with me so it looks like this at
2:00 a.m. with a nice cup of tea I al
that's coffee not alcohol alcohol will
be really counterproductive okay [ __ ]
there's some cool Mortal Kombat news and
some just regular Mortal Kombat news
that hits the junk of everyone who's in
Australia in fact we're gonna talk about
that part first
Australia has won the fight against
Mortal Kombat and banned the game
entirely yeah it was gonna get a
censored version of the new Mortal
Kombat game now it's not gonna get
anything because as all of us nerds
learned in gym and elementary school
life is just that unfair I'm sorry
people in Australia and it's really
funny because Kano is Australian Kano
the iconic character Kano to the Kay
knows
I think his ending should be a monologue
against the whole violent censorship in
Australia and all that [ __ ] just
remember video games don't create
psychos video games make psychos more
creative kind of took that from screen
but it always made sense the coffee's
really burning my hands up okay what's
the deal Australia are you guys like
Psychopaths are you really susceptible
to suggestion are you gonna rip a spine
out if you see it happen in a game where
is Australia just won by the V for
Vendetta guy but in that game mr. Creedy
I never want to say it again weird [ __ ]
and it would just be annoying if it had
never happened before but it did was
left for dead
yeah they released a censored version of
a zombie game with guns that I imagine
would feel something like a bunch of
pissed-off people running at you and you
shoot them with airsoft guns and they
fall down in there and their reasoning
behind it is because of the fatalities
in the blood is too violent and kids
shouldn't see it or play it just seems
like a really spoiled kid he's been
trying to do something for 20 years and
he finally gets the opportunity and he
wins and he gets to go hi I did it but
it's really irrelevant now because
there's a lot more violent [ __ ] out
there Mortal Kombat that's the devil and
the other bit of badass Mortal Kombat
news is that Mortal Kombat's getting a
demo on the PlayStation Network on March
15th March 8th if you have that crazy
PlayStation Gold membership or whatever
everyone knows a gamer who has it I
don't have it because I'm a really cheap
bastard you guys might not know that
about me I will not tip over 2 bucks for
happy endings no way Xbox Live members
apparently you get it later which makes
me think that NetherRealm Studios and Ed
Boon really doesn't like Xbox I mean I'm
an open advocate of PlayStation 3 over
Xbox 360 but it's almost like hate at
this point no exclusive character the
demo comes out later on the Xbox 360
Network
xboxone consume other realm Studios for
like discrimination so what do you guys
think are you gonna play the new Mortal
Kombat demo I played it at PAX but I
want to know what you think and the
banning of Mortal Kombat from Australia
do you think it's good do you think it's
justified do you think it's ludicrous
people in Australia do you like that I
would think it's dead you think it's
weird free control issues from the V for
Vendetta guy especially Aussies I want
to know what the Australian people think
about this and let me know what you
think of the game when you download it
and play it and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]